If we want to go back and ask the question,
when was Donald Trump first contagious for
Corona virus?
The answer is actually a very scary one because
it likely was during the debate with Joe Biden
on Tuesday.
Fortunately, so far, Joe Biden has had it's
either two or three negative Corona virus
tests and it's probably another day or two
before he would be completely out of the woods
due to the incubation time during which you
would not yet test positive.
But what we do know are the following.
First of all, Donald Trump lied about his
tests when Donald Trump was interviewed on
the Sean Hannity program Thursday night at
9:00 p.m. Eastern with nine or 10, I believe
nine p.m. might might be 10 p.m..
That was before his 1:00 a.m. announcement
of testing positive.
He said, I've been tested and I'm waiting
for the results.
But in reality, Donald Trump had already had
a positive rapid test at that time.
He had had a positive test and was waiting
on results from a second PCR test.
Trump already had a positive test, but pretended
that he had not.
Then Donald Trump's doctor talked on Saturday
morning, said we're 72 hours in, which puts
us set Wednesday morning.
And then later the doctor said, no, no, no,
I misspoke.
That's not true.
But already very weird.
And then Fox News's Chris Wallace, who was
the debate moderator last Tuesday between
Donald Trump and Joe Biden, said, well, you
know how everybody was tested at the debate
hall?
Well, turns out Trump wasn't really tested.
Trump showed up late and we went on the honor
system that he had tested negative.
Check this out.
Was that I arrived on Sunday.
I think you arrived on Monday.
They didn't arrive till Tuesday afternoon.
So for them to get tested, that wouldn't have
been enough time to have the test and have
the debate at 9:00 that night, they didn't
show up until three, four or five o'clock
in the afternoon.
So, yeah, that was an honor system when it
came to the people that came into the hall
from the two campaigns.
So in reality, Trump might have been positive
at that time and known it.
So they deliberately showed up late to avoid
the test.
But even without that idle speculation, there's
a bigger reality, according to Dr. Ashish
Jha, dean of the Brown University School of
Public Health.
Based on the timeline that they admit to,
Trump likely was infected between Saturday
and Monday.
That points to the Amy coni Barrett super
spreader event.
I'm talking about not this previous Saturday,
but the one before it takes five days on average
for the virus to be detected from the point
of view of an infection.
And then it can remain detectable for up to
14 days, with some exceptions.
On average, Corona virus remains undetected
for around five days after the point of infection,
which means that Trump likely was infected
and likely contagious on Tuesday, although
fortunately, as far as at least on stage,
he didn't go near Joe Biden.
And indeed, so far, Joe Biden has tested negative
multiple times after the debate.
Chris Wallace was also on stage with them
and he says he will get tested but is waiting
because his doctor told him early on you could
get a false negative.
Take a look at what Chris Wallace had to say.
Bennets You've got some people testing positive
since Senator Mike Lee, who we've learned
was at the White House earlier this week.
Can you maybe umbrella all of this for us
with what we should be watching for?
Well, I'm going to tell you what my doctor
is telling me, which raises some some questions
for me.
And, you know, I'm I'm only going to tell
you what my doctor is telling me, but it does
raise some questions about the timeline because
I'm going to have to get a test.
I'm in a in a uniquely vulnerable circle.
The three people on the stage for an extended
period with the president and the vice president
and me all without masks.
And my doctor is telling me that I shouldn't
get a test today because it takes five days
for the virus to load up enough.
And that I could have a test, but it might
well be a false negative.
The significance of that to me is that if
the president had a test yesterday and it
tested positive, then I think he had the corona
virus during the debate.
Because, you know, this talk about while he
was with whole packs on the plane in Minnesota
on Wednesday, I don't think you'd have a positive
test.
And again, I'm not a doctor.
I'm simply telling it in terms of what I was
told by my doctor.
It wouldn't load up enough to have a definitive
positive test on it for about four or five
days, which is why I'm not getting tested
until next Monday.
So Chris Wallace actually making absolute
and total sense here.
Now, why is Chris Wallace in a studio saying
this?
Shouldn't Wallace also be quarantining if
he may have been exposed and has not yet had
a negative?
Just just asking.
But overall, it is a trail of incompetence
and chaos that follows Donald Trump.
His actions and decisions and behaviors are
disastrous.
Everywhere he goes.
And this actually makes Trump's criticism
of Joe Biden during the debate for wearing
a mask, a big mask.
It makes it even more immoral and ridiculous.
Remember this?
I don't know.
I don't wear mess like him.
Every time you see him, he's got a mask.
He could be speaking 200 feet away from it.
He shows up with the biggest mask I've ever
seen.
Well, we now know that at the same time that
Donald Trump was laughing at Chris at at Joe
Biden for wearing a big mask and having small
crowds at his events and so on and so forth.
In all likelihood, Donald Trump was contagious
at that time.
How insane is this situation?
And we've better hope that Joe Biden does
not end up testing positive.
It it again, it doesn't.
Chris Wallace announced at the start of the
debate.
The candidates have agreed not to shake hands
at the end of the debate.
They did not approach each other.
At one point, it sort of seemed like Donald
Trump was going to approach Joe Biden.
If you watched that moment again, you can't
really tell.
But it's possible that Melania Trump held
him back.
Who knows what Melania Trump knew at the time
about Trump's corona virus status because
they won't answer questions such as when was
Trump's latest negative test?
They won't tell us.
Kaley McEnany has said she's not going to
tell us because of privacy reasons, if you
can imagine.
We simply do not know and are left to speculate.
How insane is this situation?
Let's talk a little bit more about Chris Wallace
now.